a while ago
um you worked on game of thrones or
developed the spin-off
um can you can you say what happened
with us
uh i mean you're not probably not
i can say that uh no i think you know it
was an amazing like i had a name
uh i had an amazing experience with it
i'm extremely proud of uh
of uh the the we did a tremendous amount
of work
i'm really proud of it and uh and maybe
one day
uh it will see you know it'll have its
moment
you know that's that's my hope for it
but uh we'll see i know
now they're they're really developing
out a lot of projects
uh in that world and uh you know i'm
doing a different show
at the network that like i say is i'm
deeply in love with
uh i am also really in love with that
project uh
i would love to one day be able to do it
so we'll see did your
series or the one you were developing
did it have a title like
how far did you get into it and or was
it sort of like you were still in like
the bible stage
uh it was it was very
developed in terms of um the world and
the bible there was
there was a script there were outlines
and i mean certainly yeah we had a title
we had
a lot of stuff got it i spoke to naomi
watts
and you know she shot a pilot with jane
goldman who you know obviously didn't
get picked up
and she still hasn't even shared images
of her costumes and everything yeah
well i mean you know it's very much like
an important proprietary brand
and i don't own it you know it's in its
hbo's
uh property and you know i'm
really proud of the work we did uh and
obviously i love them and we work
together on on other things and on this
show but uh
you know it's definitely in their court
as to you know
what could theoretically get released
this is a jokey question so bear with me
um every time we post about godzilla
versus kong
uh on in the comments and on social uh
half the responses are why don't they
just kiss
my question for you is uh so in any
version of the script
did you have godzilla and kong kissing
we never had them kissing
i regret that but i do think that in a
sense they do i mean they're animals and
animals don't
mean exactly kiss but there are moments
they have a moment of uh
uh there are moments of connection
between them i think one of the great
achievements of the film is bringing
about
uh you know whether you're a co whether
you're team kong or
team godzilla i think you're satisfied
and i think the two of them
uh without without either of them bowing
to the other
they both have their moment in the sun
and they both
uh achieve their grudging respect so for
them i think that's a
kiss you started working on godzilla
like a long time ago you you're one of
the people that worked on all four of
the movies
yeah when you when you were developing
or writing and working on it back in i
guess
2013 or whatever year it was did was the
was the vision these four films
like how much were you thinking about
what could be back then
and what actually happened yeah i think
you know it's from the very
in the beginning the idea was can we
make a godzilla film
for america american audiences that
respects
the franchise uh that has been this very
multifaceted and complicated
uh franchise and but still feel
uh you know something that godzilla fans
would appreciate and something that will
resonate
today with american and global audiences
and then as we started to feel that well
we kind of we got something here
it's working then in in and around
post-production on that film uh
legendary and at the time the head of
legendary thomas toll
uh had this notion of i wanna
build toward godzilla versus kong and
the pitch to me was can you do uh a
version of the king kong story that's
fit
in this universe and we developed this
idea of monarch this sort of
organization and
a lot of that stuff had come out as we
were doing godzilla and then
it became uh okay can we do kong
uh and uh and but when kong was
introduced
thomas's idea and ambition as a fan was
one day we're going to be able to bring
them together
and you know and so yeah it's kind of
cool to see it
actually having happened yes i'm going
to give him a lot of credit
uh and i've spoken to him a a number of
times back when he ran legendary and he
was a full geek
oh yeah absolutely he totally is and
he's he like he
just unapologetically loves uh
he loves king kong he loves godzilla i
would imagine that in the writing
process there's
all sorts of ideas that get developed
and then someone with a budget says yeah
you're not doing that
so um were there any things that you
guys came up with
or you came up with that didn't get to
be included just because
someone with a line item said you can't
do this well
i don't know if it's as simple as that
but definitely like you know
it in you know i i've been involved in
each of these movies at different phases
you know over the course of it's been
quite a few years now almost a decade
and like
and uh uh when i came into godzilla it
was
right around basically at the same time
as gareth edwards the director coming in
and we
there had been some scripts and we kind
of reinvented it and at one point
in the process uh there was a set piece
that was on
an aircraft carrier and it was like
batted around by godzilla and you were
with the people as it got inverted
and it was like titanic capsizing
with godzilla and i loved that set piece
as like i was writing it it was just
something i was really proud of and
ultimately like
it got cut fairly early on just because
of the insanity of the expense of it
and it you know uh but
then when i came back in on this project
i came in a little bit later in the
process
where we were sort of closer to uh
in pre-production and there were a lot
of the bones already in place and it was
kind of about
assembling the assembling them together
uh
and you know doing what you do when you
come in as a writer at that phase
but one of the things that i discovered
when i came back in is that you know
probably having nothing to do with the
set piece that i had once written but
like here we were
on an aircraft carrier having like a
badass fight where the whole ship was
going to get turned over and flipped and
like
it was like this thing that i had
written once before
much cooler now because both creatures
were involved
but being able to kind of dive back in
on that with like
if not a bigger budget i honestly don't
know and couldn't speak to that
but certainly like a more evolved
franchise that had grown to the place
where that was now
you know the ante had been raised to
like we have to do this kind of battle
in order to like compete with what we've
done to sort of start to top it so that
became
kind of fun i would imagine that each of
these movies
was able to like the vfx in each of
these movies
have um i don't know if they've gotten
easier or i guess what i'm curious about
is how how has the writing how have you
guys sort of worked with the vfx and
sort of crafted like what's possible
were there any things that you were
writing that just like seemed
like the vfx can't do this and now we're
at the point of like you know you look
at this recent movie
you have kong in the snow which is just
you know crazy
yeah and beautiful i thought like i mean
i you know i don't
i couldn't speak to that and i'm not
you know i'm the layman when it comes to
vfx i mean i you know obviously work
with those
incredible artists but like uh
i don't know uh what we have now
that we couldn't have done but i
definitely it's definitely clear that
like
you know i think the lessons get learned
in terms of like
you know you're dealing with like a
different problem with scale with these
creatures
like the scale of the creatures is
something that
creates you know challenges because
in reality things of that scale like
would move extraordinarily slowly
right so there's like all these things
you kind of like but so you have to
mimic that on some level and in certain
shots
uh and in other shots you want to see
them you know
throw a fast punch but the truth is like
the the way
you know the way that they would appear
uh in reality would be a lot slower just
from perspective questions and so
there's like
it's an interesting um you know
process of discovery in terms of what
those artists have kind of like
gotten better and better and better at
over time as they've like
learned how uh you know
uh how to create these scenes
uh to cater to kong to cater to godzilla
you mentioned years ago that thomas's
original vision was godzilla versus kong
you guys now made godzilla versus kong
what
was there ever something that was after
this like in terms of in the development
process or
was this is this sort of like wait a
minute we're at the peak it feel i mean
i i'm sure
you know hopefully there will be i have
no idea uh but
i uh but if not the peak at least
uh you know a a plateau that everyone's
been aiming for like this is a
this is a this is a point that has been
part of it
uh an ambition from the beginning so you
know i look forward to whatever the next
uh iteration of this franchise is
but i think the um you know this has
certainly been getting these two
characters to
it's a little like the avengers you know
it's like you build to that place and
then it's not to say there aren't future
uh movies that bring everyone together
but those are the kind of like
that's that's one goal that shouldn't be
discounted
uh what do you wish people knew about
the making of these movies
oh my you know just selfishly as the
writer i think it's fun for people to
know
that um you know as the writer it's not
the dialogue i mean that's always part
of it but that
a part of what goes into this is being a
part of building out
storytelling not just over not just in
terms of what the mcguffin is
or what those pieces are that kind of
build what you think of as story
but in terms of crafting uh the
the the set pieces and the sort of like
the beat by beat moments
that result in emotional uh connection
to these characters to the creatures and
uh
and investment rooting interest and all
those moments where you cheer
or you cry like that's part of what the
writing
of these stories is and i think it's you
know it's all done in these movies
there's such a huge
uh uh kind of group of uh
talented people working together
collectively but i think oftentimes you
know one of the things that
you know people think of the writing as
being that line of dialogue
and that's really not it right i think
there is
every now and then i have like there's a
few lines of dialogues in the entire
franchise
that i could go like oh that's one that
i that from and i remember in the
beginning
it stayed the same and it lasted like
let them fight is one that i remember
writing
and i loved that moment because it felt
iconic and cool and it became part of
the movie and it's still there and it's
an internet meme
and there's a couple of those moments in
this movie uh but
the the truth is most of the legwork
uh and the um the challenge and the
reward of it
uh is in building out the emotional
moments
like the discovery of oh what if you
know
if kong and jia sign language you know
communicate by sign
is there a moment where we lie to kong
uh about the fact that maybe his
relatives or his ancestors are
down in hollow earth because we need him
to take us there
and so there's this emotional moment of
betrayal like that's
sort of what the writing entails and as
much as
okay we want to do a set piece on the
water
uh between these two characters well
what are the different
what are the different moments like
think you're imagine you're spielberg
and you're building like a masterful
set piece like what are those out of the
frying pan into the fire
suddenly you're trapped in the waters
and your the whole ship is inverted and
the water's
you know coming up to the floor and you
know those things are all part of it
um and it's all done uh
collaboratively but it's uh that's
that's where the real fun
and the real challenge is it must be
pretty awesome to be an internet to have
created an internet meme
you know like let them fight to me
that's like honestly that's one of my
that's one of the proudest coolest thing
and it's like i remember i was there on
the
like i remember when i remember when the
line came and i remember when um
when we were looking it was very much
like oh we're looking for a trailer
moment
in that and it was like oh this feels
like a good one has no one ever said
that i mean maybe they have but i don't
remember it and then it felt like and
then
you know i remember being there on the
day and and gareth kind of
had that really like cool simple push-in
on
on uh the character and it just like can
and it was like oh that's
badass no no it's it's [ __ ] cool
um do you are there easter eggs that
have still
not been found in these movies oh my god
i'm sure
uh yeah yeah i'm sure there are i don't
uh i i like it it'd be hard for me to
point out a few but
like uh they're there yeah let me the
different question
do you think that the jurassic park
movies
exist in this universe and if so
have the people that work at apex seen
them
uh i i would say eventually to say they
do exist
because this is the it's the real world
and jurassic park
predates uh the arrivals of godzilla in
2014
so yeah and i would who hasn't seen him
so you're basically saying that the
people at apex just ignore them
well i mean you know humanity hubris is
you know is eternal we we always ignore
our own past
whether fictional or otherwise it's true
um with hollow earth uh which is like
it's just a cool like hollow earth is
cool and
how much did you guys figure out like
the bible of how hollow earth in case
you do get to make another movie or they
want to pursue this how much is all that
sort of
done i i don't you know i don't i
i don't know if someone else has a bible
to it i don't i think like it was much
more of an organic thing
uh but you know for adam i thought he
did such a beautiful job of really
like when i first came in on this film
like i said more was developed but one
thing was he had this very clear
vision uh specifically for what the
hollow earth entry would look like and
he kind of envisioned it as being almost
like the 2001 light show
and really wanted to lean into that like
laser light
kind of uh aesthetic and those like
uh those tone color tones and that whole
sort of vibe
uh and i thought he like pulled it off
magically and the
the trip to hollow earth like what i
love about it because in the script
at different times it had more
plot behind it and ultimately
we kind of stripped away more and more
of like the plot reasoning there was an
ele there's a mcguffin
is ultimately why they go down but but
less and less
of import happened there and more and
it was able to just become an emotional
experience
for kong les i mean the people are there
but it's kong's journey
it's his journey to his homeland and
and being it taking out more of the
human
sort of rigmarole of why they're doing
that and allowing us to just
live with kong as the music plays and he
has the experience of connecting with
you know what's you what is what he has
this sort of like
you know uh uh spiritual and
like uh and um kind of deep-seated
uh ancient connection to this place was
just beautiful and i had never
lived with a with like kind of a monster
or titan or any
kaiju in quite that way before uh that i
thought was really powerful
and and like beyond uh what i could have
imagined initially
completely i i think that sequence works
because you give a [ __ ] about khan
you know and you care about him finding
his family
um did you guys figure out the history
of the acts
uh i mean implied but not specifically
like to me it's like that's
you know the godzilla's scales have this
kind of conductive
radioactive quality and that the
uh the primate kongs uh
were you know had a kind of evolved
uh you know civilization of sorts you
know as primates might and simple tools
and had used the spine of a godzilla
creature
uh to create it you know presumably
there are more like it but i
feels like the iconic scepter of the
king that's what's sort of so fun about
it
could there be other titans that are
sort of asleep
in hollow earth oh i would venture to
say there must be right it's a big uh
it's a big with big hollow world but
i was just trying to piece together like
when you're watching because i saw it
twice and the second time i'm like i'm
trying to do measurements in my head
like how big is this right it's like
miles is this like
a hundred that might just be one
continent part you know like
one section of it let's say right i bet
someone has done the calculation of how
large that little inner sphere would be
one of the things
that i really enjoy about this movie and
i think a lot of fans are going to enjoy
is that
it doesn't hold back on monster action
like kong and godzilla are throughout
the movie
and can you sort of talk about was it
always designed that way like uh
i mean i guess like figuring out where
to insert the monsters yeah
i think it's one of the it's to my
knowledge it always was certainly
from the moment i came in and i think
like one of the
fun things about being involved like one
of the you know
one of the few kind of creative people
who's been involved in each of these
films in some capacity
has been being able to see how we've
you know our we we've been able to kind
of like un
uh like unchain the handcuffs as we go
on like with godzilla godzilla it was
very much about like
let's be grounded and let's like
introduce this character to the world
and it's a world a story world that had
never seen godzilla before
and so it can't just happen right away
like we have to like
tease it out and and some people
responded positively to that some people
wanted more right away
uh but there was a very conscious choice
that went in and then obviously
with kong skull island it was a little
bit more but it was
similar where it's like you you know you
build up you get to the island he's
there
you start interacting with him but
you're not he's not your main
character you still have you know these
characters these human characters who
are kind of your way in
well now i think we you know we've
gotten to a late stage of the franchise
in a good way
that's allowed us to to we've done the
groundwork of building audience
investment with godzilla building
audience investment in a different way
with kong
we understand we care about these
characters and we've earned
the fact that this is godzilla versus
khan like this is that's
they are the stars they're the marquee
characters
and all the human characters i mean
something i've learned in working on
this franchise
has been that like the best human
characters in the show
in the movies are the ones who fit the
bill
of the kinds of characters you would put
around movie stars
in movies which is which are character
character actors characters right like
you have you might have your james bond
and then around james bond
you find fun and charismatic and
humorous
and different characters who fit the
bill but you know your star
is bond and in this case your star is
godzilla and your star is kong and we've
earned that
so now the other characters can have a
little more personality
their role is not to be they don't have
to carry the film on their shoulders
they're they're in some cases our
emotional touch point as human beings in
some cases their comic relief
the the human beings become the
supporting actors
and our kong and our godzilla are the
stars of movie
and i think by we've earned our place to
that uh
in this franchise and that it kind of
makes this film
unique and special and like gratifying
and rewarding in that way i think
hey well listen congrats on godzilla and
everything and you know obviously i look
forward to talking to you about the
lakers thing
uh once you guys you know when you're
further along cool
i look forward to that thanks and also
uh in
say hi to the cats i will she says she
says
[Laughter]
by the way you you've seen that owl
kitty trailer haven't you
uh yes i have it's really funny yeah i'm
just making sure because that doesn't
look like
i know that look and i was like well
maybe he is out
i know i were but awesome man it's
really good
really good to meet you and i look
forward to another time